hello everyone and welcome to a most
spectacular game from round three of the
third leg of the video grand prix
currently being played in berlin it's
vincent kymer versus daniel dubov and uh
yes a lot of you guys have requested it
and also i would like to apologize for
triggering so many ocds with the
previous two videos i did not realize my
board was uh not aligned
no idea how this happened i did not
change any settings in my obs
probably something to do with the
website being loaded differently in the
obs but uh and now i've refreshed it and
everything
is perfectly fine so
no idea what happened there but i i have
seen how how you guys were
struggling to watch uh in in the comment
section and yes i imagine it was a a
very difficult time for you so sorry
about that uh we have fixed it now
getting back to the game uh really a
nice one so uh i hope you guys enjoy it
so vincent uh the young padawan of
peter leko
opens with d4 uh we have knight to f6 c
for e6 knight to f3 in the d5 uh we have
the queen's gambit decline on the board
knight to c3 and now
the incredibly sharp vienna variation d
captures on c4 so black grabs the pawn
here and the white will of course grab
the full center with e4 and now b5
guarding the pawn here saying that okay
if you capture on b5 i'm just gonna
capture on e4 but that's kind of the
point that white will grab even more
space in the center knight to d5 and now
comes knight captures on b5 we have
knight to b6 now guarding the c for pawn
and bishop to e2 here vincent just
prepares the castle we have bishop to e7
and now bishop to e3
we have bishop to b7 the bishop is uh
very very strong on this long diagonal
and now usually castles is a move that
was played in this position but here
vincent plays queen to c2 and it is now
already as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game
uh so do both castles we have rook to d1
makes sense uh put rook on the d file
the queen is still on the eight knight
eight to d7 and now knight back to c3
the knight is coming to e4 at some point
and then white will have incredible
pressure here
along these squares and you can see how
white has a lot of attacking potential
already with the queen attacking h7 the
bishop pair is still on the board if you
imagine something like h4 coming knight
uh knights to g5 putting even more
pressure here so black has to be very
careful and the uh pawn on e5
guarding that f6 square is making it uh
not all that easy for black to defend
usually the knight will come to f6 this
is not the case here so queen to b8 now
dubo is now ready to push c5 and this
will weaken the e5 pawn by attacking the
d4 upon the base of the pawn chain uh
castles uh and now c5 so black played
everything perfectly uh fine here there
is nothing wrong with any of this with
bishop to g5 offering a trade of bishops
but now if you just captured in white
will already have started an attack here
and not something that you want to allow
you can play g6 of course but then maybe
h4 h5 it's easy to attack such a
structure
uh so bishop g5 and now queen back to ea
the duboff says all right if you capture
i'm gonna capture bring my queen into
the game this way
i am perfectly fine with this but bishop
back to f4 now the bishop will find the
safe haven on the g3 square and bla
white will have immense control over the
d6 square with the bishop also chipping
in and the knight coming to e4 will have
sorry great control oh sorry but that
will have great control over the d6
square
so rook to c8 again a very nicely done
as the queen is on c2 and now bishop
back to g3 we have knight to d5 offering
a trade of knights uh and then now
knight to e4 what we've discussed now
the d6 and f6 squares are under uh a lot
of control from white and now knight to
b4 attacking the queen here queen to b1
and this is where things start to get
really really interesting adobe could
play a normal move like bishop captures
queen captures and now let's say knight
b6 to guard the pawn here and after a3
chasing the knight from such an active
square knight d5 and the game just
continues nothing uh you know out of the
ordinary is happening uh but instead the
dubai being double goes for a dubovian
move and plays knight to d3 and now
a lot of good things can happen for both
white and black if you do not play with
absolute precision now we've uh blocked
the queen's defense of the knight here
so we're just threatening knight cap
bishop captures knight on e4 uh but if
you capture the knight here let's say
upon captures and we're going to capture
this then we play c4 and then you've
really given black a lot of uh space to
operate now the bishop is a monster this
pawn is excellently placed here this
bishop can come to b4 really take a lot
of squares uh from uh from white's
pieces uh so maybe not something you
want to allow especially against someone
like like dubo so instead after knight
to d3 we have knight eat back to d2 uh
just putting pressure on the c4 pawn and
now comes the bishop captures on f3
bishop to a6 is another way to go about
it just guarding the pawn uh but do both
plays characters we have knight captures
and now knight to b6 putting pressure or
rather defending the c for pawn one more
time and b3 now trying to overload the
c4 pawn because if you capture then you
lose the knight here knight to d5 by do
both and now comes uh b captures on c
for knight to d5 is a move only double
would play
but that's why uh his games are some of
the most enjoyable ones so here he
allows b captures on c4 now both the
knight and d5 and the knight on d3 are
hanging we might even use this as a
thumbnail we'll see
uh and how do you how do you defend here
uh the problem is if you play knight c3
yes you attack the queen and the rook
and even the bishop here so white has to
be very careful the problem is there's
this very simple queen captures on d3
and now if after you capture on d1
because there's really nothing better
how do you continue here if c captures
on d4 we can even play knight captures
and our position is just beautiful we
still have this beautiful control over
the d6 square we still have the past c
pawn our knight might even come to d6
this is completely winning for white so
dubo obviously had something else in
mind he plays knight 3 to f4 and now uh
saying okay if you want to get rid of it
you're going to have to give up your
dark square bishop i'm also putting a
lot of pressure on the e2 pawn i'm still
preparing to capture on d4 so my
position is looking uh
well quite all right but the problem is
uh this is completely lost for duba but
you have to find uh
such a normal looking winning move uh
that it's it might be a bit too
difficult to find so feel free to pause
the video and try to find the idea that
dub of missed
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
seemingly uh well who would play this
move and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is
bishop to d3 that's the move that wins
the game and that is what vincent played
now the thing is your knight is still uh
well just stuck here on d5 and we're
also threatening bishop captures on h7
and now if you capture on d3 uh saying
okay let's just trade uh we first
capture on d5 your knight is still
hanging and we are threatening d6 and
once you move the knight or play
something like c4 to defend the knight
we play d6 now the bishop has to move
and now uh okay black also has a past c
pawn but the d6 pawn is just too too
powerful and it's also very very easy to
get rid of this pawn because you can
simply pick it up there's not much you
can do about it if queen a4 we just take
it and after queen captures we can even
play queen captures on d4 so nothing
wrong there and if black decides to push
it let's say pawn to d3 upon
here then we just trade captures
captures of course and you you really
have nothing here i mean it's only white
who who will win this so instead after
bishop to d3 do both tries rook to b8
puts pressure on the queen here now says
all right if you if your queen continues
to be on this light square diagonal then
i have knights to b4 which will be very
tricky uh but this is exactly what
vincent goes for however first of course
we're going to capture on h7 that's the
whole point uh bishop captures on h7
king the h8 and the now queen to c2 so
we have to keep an eye on the bishop but
we also know that the knight is coming
to b4 uh but it's not a problem knights
to be four by double now comes queen to
d2 we say okay you can have your bishop
we're capturing the knight here and now
again what do you play here uh if you go
back let's say knight g6 then we just
capture captures captures and yes black
does get the semi-open file for the rook
but i mean after d5 there is really no
point in continuing this game for black
another thing you could do maybe you
play something like knight characters on
g2
uh say that okay you capture then i'm
going to capture your bishop but we can
just play bishop back to b1 and we're
going to capture the knight next then
nothing fun happening here for black so
those are some of the option uh dubo
decided to play king captures on h7 but
this just allows queen captures on f4
and now c captures on d4 you absolutely
have to play this because the d5 just uh
it is just too dangerous to allow this
so c captures on d4
rook captures on d4 and now knight
captures an a2 it's a maybe a pawn grab
that doesn't do all that much but you
you really have nothing here with black
and capturing this pawn and maybe
creating your own past a pawn uh is
pretty much the only counter play you
will get so here knight captures an a2
bishop to h4 now trading off a very
strong defender here and now f6 uh it's
really
all the same what what do both plays
here he captures bishop captures we have
bishop characters rook captures and now
queen to g3 still black has to be very
careful as the rook here would hang if
the queen moves so we have uh rook to h6
now not allowing any checks along the h
file but now rook f to d1 now the rook
is coming to d7 then we will be
threatening checkmate on g7 uh rook to
c8 moving the rook away from the b8
square so now we can move our queen but
now comes knight to g5 check king g8 and
now queen all the way to a3 as the
knight here is undefended and there's
just no saving this knight so
picking up this pawn might not have been
the best idea but all the other ideas
were uh insufficient
as well so here e5 attacking the rook
here just rook to d7 we have rook to h5
now going after the knight but here
vincent finishes the game in the buttes
uh most beautiful possible way and that
is pawn to h4 and just defending the
knight saying okay now you you are
without uh any moves i'm just gonna play
queen captures on a2 there's nothing you
can do about it and there is no counter
play here or rather we could show uh
what will happen but yes it was in this
position on move 37 that daniel dubo
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here if you play
something like rook captures we capture
the knight yes it seems like you are
getting some uh some chances here
because you are threatening checkmate
and threatening the knight here uh but
it's too easy to win this just c5 check
what can the black king do you can move
it king to h8 but now comes the rogue d8
check and that's it
you either give up the queen right away
or you give it up later captures
captures queen to e8 captures and this
is now checkmate of course the knight
covers these squares so there is a
it seems like there is some counter play
here but there really isn't so of course
dubois realizes this and he just resigns
so this is the second loss for duboff
already in the first three rounds of the
of the grand prix
uh so tough a tough break for him but an
incredible victory for for young vincent
kymer uh who is uh playing uh well just
uh incredible chess and just keeps uh
improving at an incredible rate so uh
very interesting to see how how strong
he will become uh you know the the next
time we see him it's just incredible
stuff
but yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it once again uh really sorry
for uh
uh triggering so many ocds like you guys
have mentioned in the comments section i
will try to
uh uh well prevent it from ever
happening again it's just that when i
make the videos i i see a normal board i
don't see the boar and i very rarely
watch my videos before i upload them i
just upload them because i know uh that
i've said pretty much everything i
wanted to say and if i if i listen to
them maybe i i you know wouldn't enjoy
something that i've said and then i'd
have to remake them and then it would
take forever and you guys don't enjoy
this i know you guys really enjoy it um
uh you know unedited just the original
version where sometimes i
uh start talking about some stuff that
might not be all that relevant but you
get a more pleasurable experience of
enjoying the game as it is maybe
uh so yeah that's the game i hope you
guys enjoyed it really wonderful stuff
from vincent uh we'll see uh what
happens uh in the rest of the uh grand
prix uh i would like to thank j length
and consulting farbert fararoni uh
drippers cyberclub nft blueberryjean
friends twitter and rob rob for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing uh to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else is happening in the chess world uh
like the feeder grand prix and the
finals of the charity cup today so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day